how did you get mentally  and emotionally so strong where it  doesn't bother you well  you know it's you got to look at the  reality of the situation you know like  for me it's not you know you kind of got  to get over yourself  like it's not about you man like okay  you feel embarrassed you're not that  important like  get over yourself that's where you go  get over yourself right like you're  worried about how people may perceive  you and like you're walking around and  it's embarrassing because you shot five  air balls get over yourself right and  then after that it's okay well why did  those air balls happen  got it high school year before we played  35 games max  right week in between spaced out plenty  of time to rest in the nba it's back to  back to back to back to back to back to  back i didn't have the legs  so you look at the shot every shot was  online every shot was online but every  shot was short  right i got to get stronger i got to  train differently